la constitution c'est la norme suprême
toutes les autres normes françaises
doivent la respecter
elle est au dessus des lois et au dessus
des textes réglementaires c'est elle qui
définit l'organisation de l'état et les
valeurs du pays depuis sa création elle
a été modifié plusieurs fois mais alors
comment on fait pour modifier la
constitution
seuls les parlementaires ou le premier
ministre avec le président de la
république peuvent proposer de modifier
la constitution
dans tous les cas le texte devra être
voté dans les mêmes termes par
l'assemblée nationale et par le sénat
si c'est le parlement qui propose la
révision la version finale du texte doit
être accepté par référendum si c'est le
premier ministre qui demande la révision
la dernière version du texte doit être
accepté par référendum ou par 3 5e du
parlement réuni en congrès depuis ses
débuts en 1958 la constitution a été
modifiée 24 fois soit en moyenne tous
les trois ans le président peut aussi
changer l'organisation de l'état en
passant directement par référendum comme
l'a fait par exemple le général de
gaulle en 1962 pour passer l'élection du
président de la république au suffrage
universel direct
et voilà j'espère vous avez bien compris
comment modifie la constitution
si ça vous a plu vous pouvez leaké
commenter ou partager notre vidéo à
bientôt